didn't really no no double find games in
there oh I'm sorry let's redo that it's
live it's fine yeah we just roll back
time we roll back time hello welcome to
the Lobby gamespot's weekly hangout
every Tuesday 2 p pm. Pacific right here
on gamespot.com uh we've had a lot of
changes here at Gamespot we've decided
to change up the show decided to make it
a little bit longer and I'd like to
introduce I have high quality guests
three of our no our new staffers from
the world of video games uh Tim schaer
decided to leave game devel
and join us here why why was it for the
attention to finally have someone see me
I wanted to come where all the eyeballs
are what's the first review you're doing
for videogames.com um I was going to
check out that um Halloween RPG game a
little bit just subjectively give me my
um what have you heard about it I've
heard this amazing like transformative
experience to play it just better than
any scale that could be used to rank any
game well Gabe Miller was actually the
lead on that project I think it's called
what's called spook Adventure C some
Quest
yeah spook Adventures you should have
got that.com is probably not but do
Christmas is still available okay oh
yeah and BR Shoemaker from our um he
also quit yeah he quit I guess I work at
Double F now that subscription model
wasn't working out so you decided to
come over to the the world of back to
gam spot you guys have like nice wood
paneling on the floor and stuff fancy
over here you like it here yeah I have
an Oma 600 like a corner of someone's
office nice put a legend statue back
there people see I don't think people
down on the floor where nobody can see
it we'll move that up it's right beside
big rigs so that's where we put all our
best games anyway uh Costume Quest you
came out today oh yeah happy cost yeah
can I get one yeah yeah yeah yeah thanks
for helping is no you don't you know
okay do at least a couple of weeks in
double F before you get your hand clap
uh it's out four years after the first
one which makes everyone feel super old
and wow at least four years old 2010 mhm
you guys have released a million games
since then Costume Quest was our first
smaller game like after Brutal Legend we
that's when we started like let's take
this team and make four games at once
instead of like 10 years for our first
two games we made like four games in one
year two years and Costume Quest was
like the first one that we released that
was the Amnesia fortnite stuff right
fortnite is like what we call our game
Jam where we take two weeks and we just
uh make four games in a week in two
weeks and then um um cost Quest came out
of that and then um Gabe was on that and
he was the producer and then he was uh
kind of director kind of on the DLC
grubbins yeah wrote all the dialogue for
the DLC and so he was the best person to
uh run the sequel It's you're like a
completely different country in those
four years or company rather we are a
different country you are a country it
used to be a our own high LEL domain and
we are our
own DF o I like the way that sounds it's
probably if you there probably is a
country that has DF like the Dominican
fun public or something we could use I
want to live
so yeah it's uh what made you come back
to one of them you obvious you've made
all these different types of games you
one of the most like interesting
development studios in terms of like
just your reach in different types of
yeah well make sure you come on again
you when we first pitched I mean if you
remember this but when we first pitched
uh Costume Quest a lot of Publishers
were like we really like it it's
Halloween based RPG but could you take
out the Halloween why cuz like people
will only buy it uh at Halloween and
they won't buy it anymore which the
funny thing about that is might there is
this bump in sales when you launch it in
Halloween just like all games but then
the next year comes around and people
play it again like we see like people
buy it again the next year in this funny
kind of ritual like the same way that
you might when you're a kid watch the
Charlie Brown special every year and you
have that urge to like I just want to
immerse myself in the pumpkin patch
Charlie Brown the leaves blowing and The
Ghost and the um so you guys are like
the Mariah Carey of game development
wait how'd you get there from Charlie
Brown lius Mar Carey oh I see yeah the
Christmas album this is like our Mariah
Carey Christmas album did you think that
that might happen like were you
completely obl this the idea to like a
seasonal game actually of course we had
this all planned out very well out thing
but it came around and the other thing
that comes around is people's uh
remember the game because it's Halloween
oh yeah remember that it's like this
built-in marketing thing and people are
like remember that game they should make
a sequel to that and I'm going to Tweet
Tim and tell me to make a sequel and
then basically people don't know that if
you tweet enough times we legally
obligated to make a is that what
happened with grim Fango as well
apparently great yeah okay
so Corner they just ask for it we just
want to give people what they want all
right let's give them what they want
let's actually have a look at the video
game spook Adventure spook Adventure 3
this is Gabe Miller did we introduce
Gabe Miller yeah we he's playing the
game master you what we call driving
this is what we call Gleaming the Cube
this is the start menu this is also
where the DLC left off with a
cliffhanger which portal you go
through this is start menu I feel like
it's breaking some like Xbox Live arcade
rule set true we haven't passed TCR yet
so maybe that's what careful yeah great
what the heck is this this of course is
not live spook adventur assume this is
not live that was a great I knew I
should have
drove yeah don't worry we we'll try get
start a new game yeah we'll start a new
game it might have been those did you go
from a save game yeah we brought some
saves over and there direct dex's fault
whenever that happens we always blame
direct de can you remember any like
other seasonal games there was a game on
the amig I used to play all the time
called psycho Santa that was free with I
never played was there a Christmas
version of
knights really was there Christmas night
Christmas was was called Christmas
nights was any Christmas games when you
type Christmas into the Giant Bomb Wiki
what stuff comes up Christmas nice and
that's it is that a plug for the Giant
Bomb Wiki which is the keeper of all
knowledge subscribe world's most amazing
video game database so start a new
game there that saves probably
I can kill that one yeah just go to the
bottom oh okay I
see we get to see the sweet intro fixed
it here you go don't crash again if
everyone on the stream could cross their
fingers and you see how I masterfully
hacked that that's why we keep they keep
your around I've been wondering if
everyone on stream could cross their
fingers and pray to their respective
gods that doesn't crash again that'd be
Super Rad uh yeah so what made you was
it just people tweeting what was it
about this that made you want to make a
second one and I really liked it I liked
the first game it was one of the first
games it was the first game that we made
that it wasn't from an idea that I had
you know it was the idea that Tasha had
that she um had when she was a kid was
like I want to make an RPG like
Halloween she loved Halloween and um and
so I I did help a little bit with some
dialogue and I wrote some some scenes
but U mostly it was a game that people
at my company made and I got to play
like a first- timer like oh man cuz
often I you know it's all spoiled for me
because I yeah cuz you're involved too
close to it yeah I liked it it's got a
great just just like that Charlie Brown
special has this great I feel like this
mood and has this um sense of humor
they're like and yet it's got a kind of
spooky scoy thing going on I guess
whenever whenever Halloween comes around
everyone goes in and starts playing like
scary games again like Amnesia and I
guess PT this year there's probably a
bunch of people going to play or like
the old alien vers Predator this one you
could play with your kids too you could
play like families play together and you
can play them you play the switch kids
yeah I always assumed when it came out
of this you being like a a f that this
was like your so it's interesting that
actually this has nothing to do with
like creatively it was not you weren't
involved no I did play it with my
daughter she was really young though so
she could just press the x button when
it was time to launch special powers but
this time I'm hoping to she she's going
to have to be reading
it you played you play you completed the
first one as well broud right
yep he didn't say he liked it that's I
enjoyed it quite a bit stopped right
there I did play it and I had opinions
about it I finished it did you enjoy it
yeah totally that's better did you do
the review for Giant Bomb I gave it a
two out of five we bring that up Yep
they're above numbers now just beyond
yep so is this a direct sequel to
grubbin on Ice it's like start straight
away it do kind of a continuous story
yeah grubbin ends with those portals and
so it starts right here and um should we
talk about what's happening you're
actually wearing the costumes that you
had at the end of they selected one of
the portals to jump through and their
home but it's Halloween for some reason
so they're talking about that and you
actually to pick whether you're Ren or
Reynold again already or is that yet I
chose Ren yeah so you still get to pick
whether you're Rena Reynold oh I see an
evil dentist in the background people
have asked if we have things against
dentists is that everyone has it's just
incidental that he's a dentist it's an
homage to um he's a guy with problems
and he happens to be a
dentist he's a guy with problems that
just happens to be a dentist he's got
great teeth I used to have a dentist
that had really terrible teeth and then
years later I thought did she just put
on like like real [__] just to make me
freak out and be like God I better
that's a really funny dentist did she do
it over and over again every time you
came well I don't know I don't know they
might have been real she might have
actually just had really bad dental
hygiene and then made it her like life's
work to make sure that I didn't know
they had denst in England in England I
don't know what they have in England
Brad in the UK also not in the UK Brad T
makes up fake countries but at least he
doesn't rraw political borders in that
part of the world let's say you're the
worst I could I can make that mistake
cuz I'm new here but you should have
known that you lived in London for a few
years I did yeah that does make me you
didn't say when somewhere in the
Commonwealth what do you call them the W
places that have Queens on their money
just say we don't have a queen on our
money don't no we we had like animals
and stuff and then EU got involved you
never been to Ireland I've never been to
Ireland I've been you've been to Ireland
yeah did you like it I did if you could
review Ireland out of 10 points what
would you give it we don't do review
scores cuz we don't want them pulled
into critic yeah the AR Metacritic needs
a bump up if you see they'll convert
sweaters to one to 100 and then you
can't control
that so he actually get to talk to the
dentist early on he seems a little
Shifty like I feel like he's up to
something I said
scram that actually looks like Tasha
down there is that character based on
Tasha yeah so you just go smacking kids
in this whole game right you can smack
them around and you hit cops in the
belly
yeah we give the player a moral choice
you
can yeah where you at on the morality
Paragon now the game will tell you how
moral you are and you're getting this is
actually one of the environments from
the first game but you leave this pretty
soon as the evil uh scheme becomes
apparent yeah they're kind of prepping
this Halloween block party which is what
set the dentist off in the first place
wait did you just do wheelies in a
pirate costume I did what an amazing
advancement over the first game you can
wheelie are you telling me you can
wheelie in any costume any costume
that's because first of all it's awesome
to wheelie around and everyone uh wanted
to do that in the other costumes yes you
don't he's not part of a robot costume
to have we all really I'm sure that was
a much requested uh feature from the
community H speaking of which if
everyone has any questions in the
Gamespot chat um reply to me on that
chat room and I'll be sure to ask the
dudes here watch it uh oh who's he
talking to what is that character gab
that's the krocus he's a Time wizard the
krocus what's wrong with his face
it's made of a clock oh it's kind WR
with your
face see how that that's good I got he's
got clock on his face what's your
excuse I didn't know they had Dennis in
Chrono land he's got kind of a Flav of
flave clock
hang so the lawsuit's coming then mhm
it's more delicate with
it oh you know the color purple means
magic is that like a design philosophy
you guys have everything doctor told
tell people you're
dentist that's a little dainty
little so the krocus doesn't seem to
approve of that so they're going I would
suspect somewhere in time would that be
true again yes they are traveling
through time backwards for good purposes
uh I don't want to spoil it yeah we
don't know yet we'll find out shortly
we're spoiling the whole start of the
game he came back and he stle something
from the P future that looks like the
past right there yeah he went somewhere
to get that thing he went back to Monkey
Island 2 Monkey Island one
sorry W doll right that's two that's two
it was two damn it yeah so by grabbing
that thing he's released the uh relas
the
Monsters and he's harmed Halloween in
some way so why does this guy want to
stop candy um he had repressed childhood
and his mom kept him from Candy as he
grew he's obsessed with dental hygi well
if he removes candy from the world isn't
he basically putting himself up of work
maybe things true maybe he's not being
logical okay rarely is the same way
doctors go around causing accidents ah
of course yes makes sense he's obsessed
with clean teeth and he doesn't like
what candy does to
it that a spoiler that's a spoiler what
spoiler who that when he said something
it question mark oh yeah you don't know
who that guy is oh that's he had Pro
though cuz he went head first yeah
that's confidence in the time portal
that um Dennis I figur out who reminds
me of the guy who played Steve Austin's
boss and the $6 million man you guys are
all way too young I just realized I'm
I'm all alone here talking about the $6
Million Man Oscar Goldman the guy who
played Oscar Goldman come on in 2014 you
could for $6 million it wouldn't be that
impressive a man it can't even make
anure inspired partly he was like half
Steve Martin from Little sh of pars and
half duck Goldman I'm someone someone on
the internet knows who Oscar Goldman is
or all your viewers like 14 I'm sure
yeah I'm sure all the the chat is is
like a $6 Million Man guy if you were
born just a little bit older maybe what
are we talking mid 70s was 7 76 79 not
quite ask your dad missed it by a couple
years it's Everett that's ever from the
first game and
Lucy uh we we got some fat questions
coming in want me to throw them out at
you depends what they are H 889 so that
person is definitely 26 or so oh okay is
c c a single player only game or does it
have Cooperative or anything this single
player single player massively single
player but if it's a huge hit I'm sure
we'll make a multiplayer one next yeah
that'd be fun Co-op it's a good point I
mean it's a good point it would be fun
as a co-op but uh did you consider it it
wasn't so many people clamoring for yeah
they wanted more uh costumes more stuff
from the first game and a deeper combat
system is the main thing they asked for
and so that's I think what the focus of
the team has been so far you'll see when
we get into the combat that there's more
choices the player can make make creepy
treat cards have more functional use and
also the ability to scoot around on your
and Scoot around on roller skates oh I
see some sort of weird uh what's going
on this is not your I like this is the
dystopian future is that um is that that
game transistor back there this the
prepost C is that what yeah you're just
your SE and cassavan are sharing assets
yeah we're good friends all of us right
down the street game developers to share
assets are the dental drone to go around
looking for you're missing a comedy
opportunity he should be chattering his
te should be chattering the whole time
oh all right Kung Fu Crow showed up this
is obviously not called technically Kung
Fu Crow but no his name is Crest wher
he's a Crest it's Latin for Kung Fu Crow
did you say Crest Whaler Crest wher
what's a Crest Whaler Crest wher is a
term for that race of beings in the
first game there trogs grubbins and
Crest Whalers we called them Crest w in
Europe sounds fancier though I like that
Chris you guys ever have have nightmares
about your teeth yeah I have this that I
bite my an apple and they all shatter
like glass yeah is that that is that
that the Apple isn't there but the
shattering and I'm trying to put them
back in oh a real part of it I think
that's a fear of powerlessness is it and
impotence oh no I've never had
that okay so this is the combat gab how
is the combat different or is that going
to be distracting you if we ask you
these question combat a lot different we
kind of rebooted it in the old one you
kind of jumped into in the middle of the
jump there was like a qte where you
waggle the stick or hit the button a
bunch of times and we wanted it
to uh be a little more engaging less
button mashy so we moved the timing to
the the hit so you kind of have to time
it with the animation now and every
character has a different timing so it
makes it a little more interesting and
then we also added uh combos that you
can unlock this guy is sort of your your
battle instructor throughout the game so
as you uh level up he'll keep beckoning
you to come learn new techniques like
tutorial Crow you are real good at
combat I know this he's got an amazing
tutorial Crow was his first name okay
the first time I've played it too oh
really you ran the whole project and you
never yeah I refused to look at it until
it was done that's a good move that's a
good move keeps it fresh what are those
habit trails in the background is that
why crashed
earlier uh that's just how the CR he
wouldn't let anyone play it even the
testers press w a he's got a lot of
swords and he's just punching and
kicking well he kicked me in your time
as well fill up my special meters
critical eye I can cut some of those
swords just for frame rate oh sweet
Justice seems familiar like there's some
game where I seen that before what was
in that bus candy oh oh thought it was
like people I'm also distracted by
watching that bu billboard back there
with a guy chasing a bunch of horses
what was he chasing Delectables
Delectables it says creepy
treat everyone seems so nonplused by the
time
portals would you want just used to it
now these kids lives have been forever
traumatized by the actions of these
videos bad guys are trying to get in
have a Crest wer living in your backyard
one's going call Crest wer now that's
kindon
there now you can see these guys are
onto them trying to break down
so got to take the time hole to time
hole time hole we got to get get to that
doll before the Dennis does so you're
going to go back even farther than the
Dennis went we went back to the
80s what's what's the difference between
' 80s Halloween and current day
Halloween more neon hoverboards right
it's funny it's said in the bayou and we
realized that the Bayou did looks the
same in every era yeah so this is the
bio in the 8S it's probably got better
Verizon reception I
though and these guys look so adorable
they couldn't possibly be bad right Gabe
we'll see they look good they're
probably going to be your
friends that was clever having little
pig pen clouds so you don't have to show
their
feet I shouldn't point that stuff
out Trade Secrets yeah Pig Pen clouds I
that's you giving this one-on-one like
his staff appraisal live on the show
yeah just so in terms of innovation and
getting along with others give you I'll
give you as continual person give a high
three on that
one on the Pig p pig pink Cloud scale
High
three how many costumes are in this one
then hey there's an alligator uh there
are 11 there were four pre-order
costumes as well that were from the
first game but in this game you also get
to upgrade your costumes so you can uh
buy stuff from the shop that will change
the look of them and also kind of beef
them up a little bit not buy them with
in purchases but buy them in the game in
the shop with game currency real
currency what if somebody just wanted to
put a check in the mail are you going to
stop
them they can do
that I was like why did I think of that
now that candy corn seems to be a really
effective
costume yeah the Candy Corn is sort of a
meat Shield like a tank corn Shield is
he is he like the teddy bear in
EarthBound
is it the teddy bear or the dog or the
dog or was it no one of the characters
one of the people in your party doesn't
have doesn't fight for a while does he
the dog I think prayed or something like
that when you fought and then during the
boss battle he had this thing that came
out I would say the main difference
between the two games the water is
really beautiful in Costume Quest 2 see
that water that was amazing is this
Unreal Engine three no this is the uh
Buddha
engine Buddha is a coding for the engine
that started with uh look at that water
look at those sleeping
alligators you have attack where you
wake up the
alligators there attack that does
that it's coming to Tim sha for post-
release patch yeah whenever you're doing
a demo think talk about things that
aren't in the game yeah like when
whenever you're doing an interview about
games ask about DLC because that's what
everyone's already asking you guys going
to do DLC this time
around
uh the costumes are DLC really the
pre-order ones yeah you pick them up
wait you can't they're only for a
pre-order you can't yeah yeah we don't
have any postlaunch DLC not yet I'm all
right right right yeah depends how many
copies you buy that I know
of at Bulba babe 1986 Bulba Bulba babe
I'm going to guess that is a girl who's
28 years old who likes Bulbasaur will it
sport generic controllers uh will there
be sport for dual shock 4 as well as the
Xbox lay so on PC on PC yeah think just
support controllers I assume that just
general yeah yeah we've been supporting
controllers on this engine for a while
so I'm sure got pretty broad controller
support limac wants to know you guys
going to make any more seasonal Games
part from Costume Quest always talked
about let's make Christmas Christmas
Quest it was more in case we slip the
schedule and we miss Halloween let's
let's reboot this as a um just find and
replace all the purple with red and
green and you probably be fine M now is
this the part where a clown has been
eaten by bun alligators is that what's
Happening Here G uh this kid runs a
alligator farm and they rip part is
costume bit weird but not an actual
living clown no is that a normal thing
in America in the bayou the children R
Gator Farms oh yeah yeah oh yeah we all
did that's typical
mhm clown sweet costume it's not a scary
Clan though is it it's a happy Clan it's
kind of redundant scary Clan is it is
this booze back here yeah hard liquor
moonshine it's the only way I can get
through these interviews they're pretty
stressful yeah
now Monty Monte is the name of your
friend from the Bayou yeah is Monty a
bayou kind of name that sounds kind of
like an
Englishman trying to bring up England
again just because it always pisses
off maybe he's a
transient alligator's in the way okay
what are you doing you switch to clown
costume I'm going to honk him you ready
H honked out an alligator oh never this
is teaching good skills to kids yeah
yeah if you ever meet an alligator don't
worry if you have a clown costume are
based on life experiences oh that's
scary that's obviously one of the guys
from the Warriors baseball Fury that's
little
bones uh jimu in the chat says
apparently ' 80s Halloween had a lot
more razor blades than the candy you
know there's
NE AR there a lot of razor blades the I
always heard about that when I was a kid
but I never ate one I heard there's
never been a case this F there's never
been a case of Halloween candy poisoning
that wasn't traced back to the kids's
own family we didn't oh that's way
darker that's the worst fun fact in the
world yeah I like that halfway
through but there's been loads of those
ones like all the time I don't know the
actual numbers we didn't have Snopes
back then okay pre- Snopes nothing is
known before
Snopes oh is this going to be good or
bad is this your first
trick-or-treating oh good oh she's got
something she's got one of those Humpty
noses sweet sweet C hump too is that is
that is that before your time too like6
hump
hump Humpty Hump what's Humpty Hump
let's cut to that right now this could
be an age thing or could be a
geographical thing it's it's it's your
chance to do the this Digital
Underground like Humpty Dumpty the
Humpty Dance she she point out the fact
that she's having a baby something you
should mention yeah not just that you
just routinely is that what you're
referring to yeah that is the character
yes that's your chance to do hum he
wears a a big fake nose I mean I hope
it's fake and not some sort it was like
a Gro nose different though without a
mustache look at that look at the time
and energy you put into having two
different superhero costumes one for the
boys one for the
girls hey did you know we're giving away
copies of Costume Quest 2 right here on
this video game in that live stream you
can't you don't you don't just get to
watch it being played you could you
could actually with your hands you could
with using the power of social media you
could win a copy of this video game
surely for like a million
dollars setting up to say it's free no
sorry no it's it's free you don't even
have to pay a million dollars all you us
to do is follow Gamespot on the Twitter
and then retweet that thing we done
tweeted before when the show started to
do that's like two clicks you just
follow Gamespot Gamespot at video games
on Twitter you might win a copy and you
might win a copy all right here's the
clown special he's a Healer obviously
it's terrifying it's scary clown it's
scary clown and what's his power
called what a
joker lter is the best medicine laughter
is the best medicine and it you healed
everybody so what are those little icons
next to the health bars Gabe which those
are they're gone kids no not those types
the character the character types oh oh
oh on
offense when you're on offense so each
costume so if you look at the enemies
there's a little like set of teeth those
are mon types and then you can see that
Ren has a green and a red sign is sort
of like their uh resistance I guess to
the uh to those types so she's strong
against magic and weak against monster
so what are the class of this like magic
monster Tech and Tech so each costume is
it each character each costume each
costume costume is good against one and
weak against another so you actually
have to think about what costume you're
putting on before you go into battle and
uh who you have to think about what
order to attack in so you're not just
button mashing through your your guys
should you always bring candy
corn um well if you want to get the hard
corn mode achievement yeah hard corn
hard corn yeah great it's basically
taking one of your attackers out so it's
a lot harder to play with it so it takes
damage well it's a way to to add
challenge to the game to get the
hardcore achievement you have to play
the entire game with in your underwear
in your party you can't accidentally
swap out that costume where you lose the
achievement yeah that is pretty hardcore
I didn't know what what hard what candy
corn was until I played costume c one
really it's not like a thing in Europe
we don't have it just like we don't have
Dentist Philadelphia it's what it was
invented in Philadelphia is that true
did you do some research on candy corn
did you have to get sign off
Philadelphia candy corn
lines so did a lot of research is there
anything you don't know about candy corn
it's made out of like horse hoes right
it's made out of wax there's wax in
there what wa and high fructose corn
syrup first I found out there wasps and
figs and now there all figs I mean
that's all figs is it like a percentage
of crunchy part it's like part of the
actual creation method yeah now I feel
like I'm stepping on GI bomb toes the
Fig wasp helps fertilize the the plant
yeah right did you learn that on bomb
the circle of life that's the kind of
science show that is Hardcore science so
you can't eat a fig without a was
science yes exactly you're going to have
it wasp's child if you need a f a Ang I
just got a creepy treat card oh my gosh
what are those just led up and you
leveled up and I leveled up it was that
was a moment thing so in the notebook
you have these creepy treat cards which
you can equip in your deck over here
which it automatically did for me and
then I can play these in battle to have
different effects minions ATT there's 45
different uh creepy treat cards I like
that picture of a guy eating ghosts yeah
did a good job of it this is this a good
spot to to leave it for the the folks at
home to play the rest of the game sure
no we're play the whole thing we play
the whole thing here welcome G Marathon
saves me the trouble of playing it if I
could just sit here and watch game play
really it's more efficient just give it
a week and then twitch will have speed
runs already up that's awesome that's
costume
it's it's really good is it really good
really good as an objective beautiful
viewer well I didn't make it Gabe and
his teammate that's true I can say I
mean it's no Broken Age but it's great
its own way speaking of other games you
guys are working on uh when's what's the
story with grim oh Grim yeah Grim I just
uh we are what's your fish L Grim Fango
remastered Grim Fango remastered okay
we're seeing it as like we're making
like a Blu-ray of Casablanca we're not
re-shooting kasablanca you literally
took line that was in your double fine
Productions video cuz I watched it to
get all my lines I was like oh here's
what we're going to say Criterion
Collection yeah said I think it I think
it made sense cuz like some people
thought we were going to remake the game
from scratch I was like that game is fun
fine and like I said better than
kasablanca so
essentially that's not too much to say
Casablanca is ask your dad about them
this is how I treat Brad Mir in the
office every day all Brad cuz he like
doesn't know who Fonzi is like explain
but you guys are doing stuff like uh the
like there are 3D models for the
characters now like there's new lighting
new whole new lighting um um path for it
and uh we're Uprising the textures
repainting them still four3 you doing
um it was all storyboarded really
carefully to be in that aspect right to
make sure what is viewable and what's
notable so we didn't want to mess with
that but we probably do different modes
of we want to find a way of of of using
more of the screen but we're still
experimenting with that cuz in when you
HD did the HD re-releases of uh the
secret of Monkey Island it's real you're
saying HD HD H H it sounds like hate h
yeah HD when you go on that's it's in
English it's all that Dental Care he
didn't get
exact last time I get you Myer pretty
good let me see your teeth let have a
teeth te off it's good thing br's not
here he does have amazing teeth do you
guys have good deal plan and double fun
yeah he got full courage on that exactly
you guys make it a bunch of games
including well this one not this is part
of the partnership program you guys have
this is double find presents are we
talking about gang be now yeah yeah uh
by bone loaf by bone loaf bone a lovely
set of three brothers and one non
brother and of the UK Sheffield
Sheffield cool wow you got all the facts
I hung out with them during packs yeah
yeah yeah they're hilarious they
basically are like this beating each
other up yeah just beating each other up
you can tell the game's made by brothers
and uh we have you here not just to talk
about it but to play as well I don't
think that's one of them is it it is all
right cool yeah how many players four
four yeah let's uh let's try it out uh
yeah so Brad apparently you are the the
current reigning champion of uhhs uh the
corded one of yeah yeah wait I don't
like playing people who are good perhaps
self-proclaimed but yeah yeah well
Vinnie carv doesn't seem too happy about
this I said on Twitter and he was if
he's if he wants to come back and defend
his supposed title he's welcome to do so
uh what stage you want to do all of them
what's your favorite how else do you
play game Beast random ooh random yeah
let's random
okay where we going where we go oh yeah
run generator is good like say just
start start the wheel that's good five
three yeah three three
three start all right what wait how we
start oh this is the okay okay I always
press y to see who I am I'm yellow which
I think I'm a blue chicken I'm the
dragon I'm the bear it's on you're blue
chicken your green bear no red guy red
guy all right I'm going to stay up here
this is like double F versus
videogames.com versus John
bom oops I dropped him I got no no
no and Conquer yeah that's right coming
with
youer yes holding on oh this is I fell
to my death
somehow I like it you're um I think I
turned off arm strength anyway okay
we're just down to the wait how does
that work what the arm strength yeah you
can turn it on and off so that you can
like if you're holding on too long it'll
make I think it's good especially for
this level you can get uh oh you don't
want to end up in an infinite hang later
go
bear arm see AR you have arm enough you
can go all the way around my favorite
way to win by default H we were playing
a couple weeko I don't think I thought
you kill anybody I was stuck in the
thing I was off camera it's not about
killing it's about surviving oh boy and
then kill my favorite thing is to hide
so no more infinite hang is what you're
saying did you just fall off again I
couldn't get back on Wow Vin carav is
watching this and gritting his teeth bet
his beautiful
teeth can here gab oh wait no I got you
no I'm going no you guys sort it out
between yourselves this is uhoh I
died I'm sucking you
out God damn it half blue and half
white no no not again yeah see no
noit what a off the planks I can't
believe you won
Pikachu look you crying and joy fall
down I can't believe I won you
inviting law copyright infringement
claimes am I out cuz I lost twice you
out already oh there I am no no I'm
fine yep I earn that one what was I
doing I was off screen and I just fell
to death out of nowhere H we played this
a couple weeks ago and one of the guys
had a sombrero on and got like stuck
between the planks yep the somero is a
tacal uh tactical Som tactical SoMo is a
good name
for oh there I am no no how do you
holding
in I'm yellow R you're green right yes
okay no you
lying they died three times I would
fight so again to confirm I cannot hang
forever no okay
it's going to cause me some problems
screaming yes in the back of no no this
is it it's like the end fight of the
Matrix mhm with drunk cosplaying babies
down you go down you go
mhm God damn it get away from me oh he's
grabbing you in the worst way got one
yeah that's right fall fall one on your
hand and one on your
kidney is that MLG down you go style
Gang Beast he's got you by the ear oh
yes yes yes yes yes yes stay up oh my
God yes oh
man one more made it yeah one more oh
Subway this could last forever yeah oh
please why did you guys take the ramp
out or no you didn't make it but why did
they take the ramp out which ramp there
was a ramp in the AL oh you're right
they did yeah yeah so back up want there
there's a way to kind of jump if you
grab jump and then you let go and you
grab again you can kind like pull
yourself up that's Advanced uh so Gabe
one thing if you're on the right you die
last oh I forgot how to oh [__] I forgot
how to climb how do you climb again you
know you grab and you jump and let go
it's hard I don't think it
matters I'm not Esports enough to to
climb are you guys bringing this to e is
somebody still alive trying to
par I want to know you
guys I thought I could get you by hiding
hiding is favorite thing in crafty
schaer are you guys going to I want to
know if you're going to add a like Royal
Rumble mode to this oh man for use at
the next packs panel yeah I'm still bit
about not getting invited this same here
man you didn't I'm going to boycott that
thing even though they never invited
me what's that
do Dr Rice
off oh that'd be so good I mean this is
this is truly the best wrestling game
ever made next time for
sure with camera no
no oh come on oh no no no no no no no no
I'm too young I'm too
pretty that's the cffs oh this is not
good yes really can't do I push the
button for the train You' got two trains
push where does that escalator go
nowhere let's go see I can't remember
how to climb you can do it you climbed
up like I know but that was that like a
month ago oh look I'm doing it you're
climbing up the
wall uh uh you make it here let me off
you my hand you my head you should have
listened to
me died in my arms on the railroad track
should I mention this game's available
on Steam right now it's in Early
Access I forgot what color am I'm
Pikachu I'm emboldened by my victory
wait did I just die fell over for no
reason there you go throw traffic to
somebody there you go there you go get
out there no stop struggling struggling
just makes it
harder
aha no no oh what are you doing no no no
I'm trying to do some some Parkour not
parkour what's the ground dancing what's
the dancing fighting thing CAA
C nobody in these
rooms there's nobody in these rooms I'm
back here oh wait that door's open come
back here this is that's a good hiding
place this reminds me of the I'm going
to beat you red body is still down there
just dead with this
cone is is this a working elevator wait
is that a ramp over there the elevator
does
work the elevator took a long time oh no
no no no
no give him a hand Gabe I wasn't
thinking straight help me up how do you
you just doing this that's good little
move oh this train will fix things hold
on oh you almost got it oh that's the
worst way too cuz if you run over you're
dead but you were just kind of like
brown
like rolled like a little Play-Doh snake
how much time did the development team
spend in the London undergrounds doing
research for this every day every day
oops this kind of looks like Shepherd's
Bush at about 1: in the morning what
who's shepher
sharper away away I'm going to have to
remember how to climb if I'm going to
defend my
title I just climb up anywhere oh wait
that's not that's notation there's
there's some Nuance to it that I can't
remember there's Nuance gy beasts it is
well you have to hold on then you have
to let go jump and grab again
right no oh I think I just
remembered yep are you doing are you
doing a different arms get down here get
down here get down here oh ready to
tangle oh now you're so tough you can
climb a wall wall no how' you guys get
hooked up with bone WF anyway we
partnership come about I believe Greg
didn't they mail in the uh Indies at
Double
oh really they did
yeah yeah we our first dou Vine presents
game was escap Bo 2 which is awesome
yeah we have that on the show our first
ever show I think that was a lot of
fun and your first ever show that's our
first ever dou presents and then no um
[__] I don't know if last life or
Mountain came
next last life a Kickstarter for an
adventure game that is in production
down there quit City Metro last life and
then uh Mountain David O'Reilly's uh
game at the with the mountain in it I
not having
mountain and then these guys mailed us
and we're were like let's check this
game out and then we started laughing
and playing immediately I it's not it's
not a game that takes too much time
before everyone's just like ow that
looks so violent oh I'm always just
taken with the kind of adorable level of
violence that it has you know what I
mean like it's oh no don't don't mess up
for me oh this was always going to
happen I'll just casually walk to the
right of
you and and I think they'll be
fine why is this not working
anymore why did you have to turn off the
arm strength D go to the right of him
that's not good get to that point how
did you get past that point that's not
really going to help like up like this
oh maybe why hump the wall yeah but
that's it no no no no no no no no no no
no no oh what just happened killed
yourselves do we walk into a death thing
all right who's in the
final not
me it's team double F come here dragon
come here you little come here you
little don't even I float like a
butterfly you're just running like a
chicken come on you're running like a
chicken I'm running like a
dragon no no no no okay no jump grab
kick jump wait jump grab y down down YB
X bone Loa help me out quick mail me
mail me the answer tell me how to climb
a
wall
I know there's a way see it's a deep
game you you should just it's easy to
pick up and play but there's this really
complicated climbing thing you're still
learning still learning the depth of
this game and the Mastery Gang Beasts
made by available now do you guys do you
have any little tidbits about what to
expect in the next update mortal tidbits
yeah I don't I know some of their their
plans about the um how where they're
going with a single player campaign of
it I'm just something dirty was
happening on the screen um um I don't
know the exact next update where the
next feature is do you know
Greg Greg knows just BR come on Greg
come on you get out my mic cuz I don't
know when the next update is
speaking hi I don't I think I'm on here
hi guys hey Gang Beast yeah what's
happening in Gang Beast uh yeah I don't
know exactly what the next update is
like that's why we called you over but I
do know plans so uh yeah there's like a
there's a single player co-op mode which
is kind of like Streets of Rage style uh
double dragon against a AI so that's
coming and then lots and lots of maps
and modes and things like that um yeah
so thanks be fun lots of punching and
kicking beating up I wasn't did I win
for you I think I won I was I was
looking at Greg good job I think I won
you can H we got a bunch of people who
won copies of Costume Quest 2 Tim could
you could you do us the honors okay I
hope none of these are dirty these all
people watching on
gamespot.com at Omega nightmare sure is
that omegan is it like Megan omegan
nightmare or if it is it's really clever
omegan nightmare okay no no feel free to
analyze every one of them rain one is
that like rore one klar klar dat
someone's in here editing this document
this creepy uh data cat data cats that
sounds like a company I think that was
just a plug for a company
Dees
d samr d
Mano one of these is going to you get a
lot of like OB XX nuto F
420 like my huge whatever Mike D yeah my
James
Knack deage
deage rival child Spirit of jazz with
three Z's and then someone's just typing
dirty words in here on this Google doc
yeah great balls deep also W a copy
wonderful ball Yeah Tim schaer have to
give balls gab maer thank you very much
for coming on sure really appreciate
it yeah and bra thank you for coming on
as well wait wait didn't who won cuz
you're the Undisputed I won the first
one right champion who won that little
round that we were playing with
nonstandard rules I kind of remember it
as me winning I wasn't really paying too
close attention but I kind of have this
feeling that I want in terms of most
death by train you nailed it absolutely
perfect I think that was hardcoded into
the game okay if Tim Schaefer then then
death by train H thanks BR for coming on
uh Vinnie is coming on next time because
you
suck